never look
back and simply learn to get ahead Jess
Danish a civil engineer turned data
scientist who decided to Simply learn
possible with a course from a premier
[Music]
University true champion who upskilled
to win
big how big a massive hike that
transformed my life Danish change gears
pretty early in the race but pron wanted
to explore more to get ahead isar simply
learned from mechanical engineering to a
data analyst and a podcaster in his free
time career transformation bro simply
learn industry
experts data
expert
difficult with a well structured course
it felt like a piece of cake that is
simply awesome what's also awesome is
that no longer nin didn't choose a quick
fix he just added data science into the
mix nin how did you Chang the game
worked on real industry problems to
become the real deal a joint family a
regular job responsibilities but nothing
could stop methan from getting ahead
what an allrounder de Hoya night with
flexible learning you can always make it
right passion
situation you too will find your way to
get ahead when you simply learn shortcut
simply learn get ahead with simply
[Music]
learn
recording in
progress
hello and welcome everyone
uh hope I'm audible to everyone can you
please confirm on the chat
everybody great great thank you
guys we'll just wait for a few more
minutes before uh we begin
again hope everybody uh can see my
screen as
well great great great great thank you
meanwhile everybody joins in I would
request everybody to tell us from where
which part of the country or the world
are you joining us from can put in your
state or city or country you're joining
us
Delhi hyad
Mumbai
Jen
chenai Gujarat
Hyderabad that's great to see we have a
wide audience today solapur Maharashtra
Indonesia Kerala Bangalore
udisha that's good to see we'll just f
for a few minutes uh we waiting for our
guest to join
in hello and welcome everyone to our
webinar
today just wait for a couple of minutes
before we
start
abishek will'll be join we'll be
starting the session in a few more
minutes I will mute
so just waiting for our guest and M to
join
the
yes uh I'm sorry for the delay guys
today uh we just about to
begin
hello and welcome everyone Welcome to
our webinar today uh we'll be learning
how to deploy a multitimer web app with
Amazon sqs uh we will also have a
program preview of the IIT goart
professional certificate program in
cloud computing and devops today uh our
guest for today is
mrani he'll be joining us in a few
minutes uh meanwhile we can set up some
ground
rules uh let me set up some ground
rules hello Mr Pam sir Welcome to our
webinar yes we just getting started so
uh for the audience uh let me put up
some ground rules yes you can put up
your question uh questions in the Q&A
box below yes the session is being
recorded and you can expect a followup
email with the recording link and
webinar certificate
uh to uh request for the proof of
attendance you will have to fill up the
post webinar survey which you will be
getting once you leave the webinar so I
request you all to stay till the end of
the webinar and fill in the survey as
well coming to the agenda of the meeting
today we will be obviously discussing
about you uh then M Dr Pam will be
taking us uh over the multi-time web app
how you can de deploy one with Amazon
sqs on aure we'll also have the pr
program introduction of the IIT cart
program in cloud computing on devops
followed by the enrollment steps for the
program and finally we'll have the Q&A
session uh at the end so I request you
all to post your questions in the Q&A
box and please avoid it to add it in the
chat so that we don't miss
out uh before we begin I have a quick
Poll for all of you just to understand
the The Experience level of our audience
today uh I quickly launched the poll uh
you may be currently studying you may be
0 to 3 years 3 to 5 years or more than 5
years of experience you can punch in
your
responses I would request all the
participants to enter their
responses I will keep the poll open for
another 5
seconds I would request all to punch in
your experience
level
thank you all uh I'll end the
PO as I can see uh almost 30% of our
audience is currently staring 25% of our
audience is in the 0 to three years
bracket about 14% of our audien 3 to 5
years of experience and about 32% are in
Workforce for more than 5 Years thank
you all for your responses moving on uh
let me introduce simply learn to all our
audience today simply learn is the
world's on number one online boot camp
we have been in the industry of digital
skills training for about 13 years now
and we have trained over 5 million
Professionals in over 150
countries let me introduce our guide for
today M Dr purushotam assudani he's an
assistant professor in the IT department
of Shri Ram Baba College of Engineering
inur I would request Dr P
please yeah sure thank you thank you AE
right so um hello everyone and welcome
uh I welcome all of you here so uh a
very good evening to all of you and good
morning and good afternoon to others
those who are in different time zones as
well so uh as rightly said uh so I've
done uh I'm I'm I'm working as an
assistant professor in information
technology department in Shri Ram debaba
College of engineering and management
nagpur and I have done my research uh in
resource scheduling in cloud my PhD in
Cloud Computing from viit Valor I
basically a Solutions architect
technology Enthusiast consultant and
trainer certified Cloud professional
innovator and
educator I am a uh Microsoft certified
trainer aw certified trainer aw
certified uh Solutions architect
professional which is the top level
certification on AWS in the architect
domain AWS certified Solutions architect
associate aw certified practitioner
Microsoft aure administrator Oracle
certified associate working as a
corporate trainer um in multiple
multinational companies have delivered
the uh trainings on AWS assure and gcp
just to name a few like Toto Cap Gemini
Mercer b s declines VF for UK ter Africa
uh etc for AWS and Azure Solutions
architect level trainings okay then I'm
also Associated uh with multiple uh uh
iits and celtech University USA uh like
and IIT I goar I khur for delivering
their cloud computing programs um
through simply learn and many others
correct so uh that is there uh right um
so that is in short about me right and I
specialize in uh Cloud platforms
operating systems distributed systems
right so these are my areas of
specializations I'm a Google Scholar as
well right thank you great great thank
you Doctor uh Welcome to our webinar
today and we are honored to have you on
thank
you moving on uh another quick poll
question we want to ask our audience why
are you attending this webinar today uh
it can
be just quickly launch the
poll uh you can are you looking forward
to become a cloud professional or are
you you want to learn a new language or
skill or you here to understand how
cloud computing ands is easy to learn or
are you just interested in working on
new projects by portfolio I would
request all of you punch in your answers
uh it's a multiple choice question so
you can multiple options as
well keep the pole open for another five
minute 5
Seconds thank you all for your responses
uh let's begin with our session for
today I would request Dr P to take over
and explain the project for us today
sure yeah thank you actually
right guys so let's begin uh with the
things then right so we are here to
learn um to as in how to deploy a
multitimer web application with uh
Amazon sqs uh on Microsoft Azure so here
we will be using Azure as well as AWS so
I'll be using the Azure compute services
like vmc nure to deploy my web
application on AWS like correct uh so so
I will be using Amazon sqs on AWS plus
RDS service to put the uh put the data
and we'll be using the uh servers in
Azure to do so right so we'll get
started right so maybe have the next
slide yeah so this is the architectural
diagram guys that I have specifically
drawn for you here so see what we are
going to do in this project is something
that I have tried to specify with this
diagram so see what we are going to do
basically is uh first of
all we will go to AWS and we will create
a user in AWS okay an IM am user okay
and uh to that user we will specify we
will give two policies okay that is an
Amazon sqs full access policy okay now
understand this thing very clearly okay
because uh this is very important uh
basically this is the Crux if you
understand this uh then of course we
will have to go and execute it correct
so uh we'll be specifying two
policies uh okay so uh we will uh we
we'll create I'll I'll just create a
user in AWS and then I will give that
user the Amazon sqs full access policy
and the RDS that is relational database
uh full access to that particular user
correct now why I'm going to give that
guys because I'm going to create a sqsq
in AWS and a database that is an RDS
database in AWS so uh the point is that
uh since this user should have access to
that sqsq plus the database I will give
these policies to my user okay that is
to my IM am user and then the point is
guys that I will also give the CLI
credentials to that user okay so I am
going to um go to that user and I'm
going to activate that user CLI
credential so that this user can login
through C that is command line interface
okay so this is what I'm going to do
with this user in AWS okay then what I'm
going to do next thing is I'm going to
create an sqsq in AWS I'll just create a
plain sqsq in AWS okay and then I'll
create a database in uh AWS again a
plain RDS database in AWS this is these
are the next things that I'm going to do
now why I'm going to create the VM cure
I'm coming to that so just hold on have
patience and then listen to it and then
see to it that you will get it after
this okay so uh I'll create a sqsq in
AWS then a database RDS database uh
server in AWS and then in that RDS
database server what I'll do is I will
just connect through a client client
from AWS that can be from my laptop any
client I can use and I can connect to
that database server in AWS and I'm
going to create a database there and a
table there okay so I'll create a
database and a table there okay and then
table that I'm going to create in that
database that will be an empty table
initially okay that will not have any
records initially okay and then guys
then what I'm going to do is then I'm
going to go to Azure and I'm going to
create the servers in assure so I am
going to create two VMS in assure two
servers in assure that is um a front-end
virtual machine in aure one virtual
machine uh which I'll use as front end
and one virtual machine which I'll use
as backend in Azure now why I call them
as front- end and backend VMS I'll tell
you the purpose of that but uh see
uh first of all let me tell you what
this frontend VM is going to to do so
the job of this front end VM what I'm
going to do with this frontend VM is I
am going to insert some messages in this
sqsq through this front end VM of azure
so now the VM will be in Azure and the
messages I will put put from my Azure VM
but where I'll put those messages in
sqsq in AWS correct so this is CR
crossplatform okay so from Azure VM I'm
going to insert some messages in my a
AWS sqsq so basically sqs is simple
queuing service in AWS now see you must
be aware about these Services of course
if you have to get this lecture because
the point is that I cannot give you the
details of these Services um because of
the timing constraint and we are here to
discuss on these services so the point
is that just I'll give you a gist um on
this so sqs is basically a queing
service in AWS uh in which you can
insert the messages and then you can
pull those messages and you can process
those messages so it's it's a pull based
uh service basically so if you want to
process any message from a que so you
just pull it from that sqsq and then you
can process it correct so any server can
do that so the point is that we are
going to put the messages in this sqsq
from our VM of azure so this is CR
crossplatform from from from from Azure
VM we are going to put the messages in
uh AWS q
sqsq and then guys what I'm going to do
is I'm going to use my another azzure VM
another Azure virtual machine and that
Azure virtual machine will actually pull
the messages from this Q from this sqsq
and we'll not just pull this messages
from this sqsq but but we'll also insert
will also put those messages into my RDS
database servers database table okay so
that messages which this Azure VM will
pull from the sqsq it will insert it
into the a WS RDS database table correct
so here this backend assure VM will do
two jobs it will pull the message from
the AWS sqsq and will put it in a table
in the AWS RDS database correct so that
is what this another Azure VM will do
and not just it will not just pull the
messages from this sqsq and but it will
also delete the messages from this sqsq
so once a message has been pulled from
an SQ from this sqsq and it has been
inserted in my database in the table in
my database then it should be deleted
from this sqsq because see the job for
sqsq is that um once the messages are
pulled from an sqsq and if they are
processed then they should be deleted
from that sqsq so that no other process
will process the same messages that are
there in the sqsq okay I mean that are
already processed those messages should
not be processed again and that's why
that would be done uh once only so when
this backend we M will pull the messages
from this sqsq it will put it into the
table in your database and also it will
delete those messages from this sqsq
right guys so that is what the thing
will happen here now instead of these
Azure VMS I could have created the VMS
in AWS also the ec2 instances in AWS
also but the title of our webinar is in
fact we do the same same thing in AWS
also but we want to work with multiple
clouds that's the title of our webinar
is that we want to uh deploy uh the sqsq
from the Azure VMS correct uh correct so
so so the title of our webinar says that
we have to make use of azure Service as
well and AWS Service as well that's why
I'm going to use the VMS in Azure here
correct guys and to put uh the uh the
importance of this IM am user here see
this this frontend VM how it would be
able to put this messages in the queue
and this backend VM how it would be able
to pull the messages from this sqsq and
will put and will insert it into the
table in your database how they will be
able to do it guys because see these VMS
are in Azure but this sqsq and the RDS
table the databases in AWS so how these
VMS will be working with these AWS
services so the VMS in aure how they
will be able to access the AWS Services
guys how they will be able to
communicate with AWS services so for
that this user of AWS will come in
picture so you remember this user that
we have created in AWS we have granted
him the CLI access so we'll Grant him
the CLI access and we have given this
user the sqs full access plus RDS
service full access so when from the
Azure VM we'll be able to log to this
user I am user of AWS why we'll be able
to log in because that user will have
the CLI credentials and through the CLI
credentials to the access key ID and
secret access key of this user we'll be
able to login with this user in are
front end and backend VMS of azure and
once we are logged in through this user
then this users will have the RDS and
sqs full access so through this users
these front end and backend VMS will be
able to access the sqsq and AWS and the
database in AWS correct so that is what
is going to happen here so is it clear
to all of you yeah that how these Azure
VMS will be able to access the uh sqsq
and the database of AWS with the help of
this IM am user in AWS to which we'll
give the RDS and sqs full access and and
we'll give uh we'll enable it CLI
credentials so through that through
those CLI credentials we will login this
user in Azure and AWS VM and we will
access this sqs and um
the uh what the RDS table right so uh
this is what we will do it through this
user right okay from these VM so is it
clear that how these VMS will be able to
access uh these Services um um uh I mean
uh in AWS the sqs and RDS service in AWS
the Azure VMS how it will how they will
be able to access it through this user
so is this clear guys then we'll see it
in lab exactly how it would be done but
then is the process clear to you is the
concept clear to you is the architecture
clear to you as in how you have to
basically do it
yes can you give me a
confirmation is that clear yes I can see
from all of you yeah there's just one uh
we said No Maybe So uh yeah so just for
that person I'll just tell you see um
you once again so see you will login
into your Azure VMS but you will log in
with this user now how will you log in
with the AWS user on Azure VMS because
on the AWS user you have to uh you have
enabled what the the CLI access so it
will get the uh access key ID and secret
access key so with that CLI access uh
you will be able to login from this IM
user in your Azure VM and once you do
that since on those user you have
enabled RDS and sqs full access so with
the help of that user you'll be able to
your VMS will be able to access the sqs
and RDS service in AWS correct so that's
how it is possible and yes it will
happen over the Internet there was one
query I think uh so yes uh these things
will happen over the Internet okay so
that is
there uh right so um we will go and we
will see this uh right so uh may I
request now to go to the next
slide so see the services that we are
going to use in this particular project
here we are going to use on the adws
side we are going to make use of
identity and access management I am
Service as I've already told you plus
the sqs simple Q service then um the
relational database service that is RDS
and on the assure side we'll be making
use of virtual machines vmc aure yeah
next
please so what would be the use of these
different Services okay so um so first
of all IM am uh so in IM am um I am
going to use am so uh basically with IM
am um it will be used to create a user
and Grant CA access to it so I'll create
a user in IM am and I'll Grant him the
CLI access then I'll provide RDS and sqs
full access policies to the user again
okay so to that user I I'll specify RDS
and sqs full access policies I've
already shown you in that diagram then
of course uh with that user I'll log to
Azure VMS also so to log to Microsoft
Azure VMS through this user so that is
what the IM am users role would be that
is what I'm going to use do with IM am
here next
please then with sqs what I'm going to
do I'm going to create a queue in AWS uh
with sqsq then I will insert the
multiple messages to the que from
frontend VMS of Microsoft assure so from
frontend vm1 of Microsoft Azure I'm
going to put multiple messages to my
queue and then um uh from this queue I
will pull and delete the messages also
from the queue and will'll store it in
the Rd s database and that will be made
possible through the backend VM of uh
Microsoft Azure that is maybe backend
vm2 of Microsoft Azure I'm going to do
that right next
please then of course with rdsc uh we'll
use RDS service to create a database and
a table in RDS through the RDS client so
we'll create RDS server first and then
database server and then through uh
we'll create a database and a table in
RDS uh database server through a client
uh and then we'll uh we'll we we'll
store the records retrieved from sqsq by
backend
vm2 of Microsoft Azure correct so
whatever the backend VM uh two of
Microsoft Azure will retrieve the
records from sqsq that will be inserted
in my RDS database in the table and of
course um we'll be using RDS to provide
the results when the records are queried
by the client from RDS database so once
the data is present in the RDS database
I'll show it to you we can retrieve that
data from the client uh of RDS so we can
retrieve the data from the tables in RDS
right so that's what we will make use of
RDS for let's go ahead next RDS is
basically a relational database service
in AWS correct wherein you can create
your databases your
tables then about Azure VM so uh see
with Azure VMS so user from AWS
uh I it should be am okay so user from
AWS am will login to front end and
backend VM of azure
correct uh so because that user will
have the CLI access and then through
that user I'll be able to login onto my
Azure VMS with those users credentials
through those users and then front end
Azure VM with that user credential will
insert the messages in my AWS sqsq and
backend assure VM will pull and delete
the messages from AWS sqsq and will
store them store those messages in my
AWS RDS database so that's what is going
to happen guys so whatever I had shown
you in the diagram I've just written
that in the form of uh that which
service is going to be used in which
manner what we are going to use with
which service guys so then if you are
all good with this shall we go and maybe
we can see a lab on this right guys so
shall we go and see a lab on this
then yeah yes sir yeah you can take over
okay please so uh yeah so uh maybe uh if
you can give me the access yeah so I'll
just share my screen and then we'll get
started with the
lab okay fine I hope uh you can uh see
my screen and I'll just get
into AWS maybe first okay so first I'll
go to
AWS okay so I'll just go to
aws.amazon.com
I log in into my AWS console guys just
give me a moment let me get in the
username and
password uh where it is where it is yeah
here it
is okay I just say sign into the
console
fine uh so I'll just go with the root
user I'll say
group uh one
second password and just give
it
okay so see we are seeing to set up the
decoupling of multitime web application
deployed on aure platform using sqs
service offered by AWS
correct okay so the steps that we are
going to follow guys here I can just put
it in the notepad also here a bit
uh so see
uh uh we'll create exess key pairs in
AWS service by creating the user then
we'll create sqsq in AWS we'll create
RDS mySQL database instance in AWS we'll
create two virtual machines inure then
we'll structure the M as back end and
front end by uh the by using the Python
scripts and then we will see the testing
of our application correct guys so uh
let's do it let's do it one by one so so
uh let's uh first create uh the user in
IM okay so I'll just go to IM am service
here and we'll create a user in IM
am
so I'll go to
users and then I'll say create a user
okay and I can give any name to this
user guys okay so uh I can I can give
any name to my user let's say I'll give
it the name as user one okay and then I
will provide him the Management console
access I'll give him a
password
okay and then uh I'll just go next now
see I will attach some policies to this
user okay and which policy guys I told
you Amazon sqs full access and RDS full
access so you can just search for those
policies here okay so I can just say sqs
full
access see Amazon sqs full access you
get it so just select this and then the
other one I can just say RDS full access
so I'll just say RDS full
access so you need to give these
policies isn't it otherwise uh you will
connect through this user on your Azure
VMS but if these users don't have these
policy so how will you be able to access
the RDS database and your
sqsq uh from uh uh from Azure VMS with
the help of this user so this you this
user should have that access
okay fine so that's what I'm I'm
specifying this user the access to sqs Q
full access and RDS full access okay so
these two access is provided and that's
it and then we can just say review and
create and we can create this user
guys okay so we can just create this
user so now see we have created this
user so this is all good now we can just
return to the users list I'll say
continue I remember the username and
password of this user so now guys the
next thing is I am going to go to the
security credentials of this user now I
am going to do what I am going to enable
the CLI access for this user okay so
I'll just go to security credentials of
this user correct and this is an
important step so see in security
credentials I am going to go to
what not the exess keys directly but I
am going to go to uh one second I'm
going to go to security credentials and
then I'm going to go to create an access
key of course in Access keys I'm going
to say create access key now when I say
create access key so it will create the
access key ID in secret exis ke now you
can yourself tell me which option I'll
go with CLI local code application
running on an AWS compute service third
party service application running
outside AWS are there so can I not go
with application running outside a WS
you plan to use this exess key to
authenticate workloads running in your
data center or other infrastructure
outside of AWS that needs to access your
AWS resources correct guys yes or no so
shall I not be choosing
this
yes so that with this user I can provide
my assure vmc access to my AWS resources
can you please confirm yeah so shall I
not give this exess this c key I should
generate yes or no
can give a yes or no in the chat window
so through this exess key of my AWS user
I can just log in from my assure VMS
isn't
it to this user yes or no guys you can
put up a yes or no right I can see a yes
I
think no I won't select normal CLS in
CLI I'll select this because I want to
uh provide my Azure vmc access to AWS uh
service is like sqs and RDS um so I'll
go with this option application running
outside AWS
correct okay fine right Kasin okay so
I'll go with this and then I'll say next
and I'll say create access key and guys
do save this access key ID and secret
access key because this is going to be
required so you can download it correct
so when you will connect to this user
from aure VM so this access key ID and
secret access key is some
that I'm going to need at that time
correct so it has been downloaded in my
downloads correct I can just open it
later I can use it as well correct so
this is the access key ID and secret
access key of this user all good I've
created this user all fine guys now
before going to Azure VMS and connecting
to my sqsq and RDS in AWS from my Azure
VMS through this IM am user
guys I'll have to create the sqsq and
the
and the RDS database in AWS first isn't
it yeah so shall I go and create the
sqsq and the RDS database server in AWS
guys and then go to the Azure VM yeah
can I get a confirmation
here shall I go and create the sqsq and
the RDS database
then
yeah yes okay let's go and do that then
so I'll just go to sqs then and we'll
create a q in
sqs
right
then so let me create a queue in in in
in in Amazon sqs in AWS
okay so I I have searched for uh sqs
service and then I will go with simple Q
service okay and then I'll create a
queue so I'll just go with standard q
and then I will give it a name name
let's say I will give it any name so
I'll give it a name let's say demo Q
demo hyphen
Q okay and then I will keep all other
things as default and I'll just create
this que okay I am not discussing on any
other thing guys because I'm not
discussing on sqs here correct okay so I
will leave all other things as default
and just I will go and uh
create this queue okay
one second
here so let me just create this
queue
now see once this queue is created guys
just copy the URL and arn of this queue
this may be required later so I'll just
copy the URL of this CU because this is
going to be required
later okay and then I can just put it
maybe
uh here I can put
the sqs uh
URL okay and then I can uh put the uh
Arn of sqsq so I can just save it
here sqs
Ern okay I'll just minimize it I will
need the URL at least at the later uh
stage correct so I've just created the
que just specified the name of the queue
and then all default settings and that I
way I have created this queue guys now
um let's go to RDS and create a database
server in RDS correct so let's do
that so create the RDS mySQL database
instance in AWS okay so let's do
that so I'll just search for RDS service
now relational database service and
we'll go in do
that
so let's uh do
that okay and I'll say what create a
database here in
RDS and then I'll just just go with this
option let's say standard create okay
and then I will choose the engine so I
want to create what Aurora database
Maria DB post SQL which database I want
to create my SQL database so I'll go
with my SQL then I'll um go with uh
what a free tier option guys okay so my
SQL the default version I can go with
whatever is shown
here and then I'll go with the free tier
option because I don't want to get charg
for this I can create an RDS data based
introduction or dat test environment
again guys I'm not here to actually
teach you on RDS service If U that would
otherwise would have been a separate
session so I'm just using this database
uh when in U I assume that you know RDS
or even if you don't know you are coming
to know that how you can create your
database in RDS correct so I'm just
going with the free tier here then um
select the template type as free tier
then um of course
uh no they are path based resources
abishek
right okay RDS and sqs platform as a
service these components right okay then
guys uh okay free tier I'll go with and
then in the database instance identifier
I can give any name so let's say I'll
give the name as AWS
gurus
okay then in the password
uh like Master username again I can give
any name let's say I again give the name
as AWS gurus okay and then uh in the
password I'll again say let's say AWS
gurus and then I'll confirm the password
as again AWS gurus okay guys just for
the purpose of remembrance I'm just
giving the same
names then
uh uh this is all
good
instance configuration I can go with db3
micro that is fine and then the storage
uh I'm good with 20 GB of storage here
storage Auto scaling I don't want then
connectivity um see um I don't have an
ec2 instance to connect to this RDS uh
resource right so uh I'll say don't
connect to an ec2 compute resource
that's fine uh VPC I can go with default
VPC and default subnet now public access
I'll say yes now why I'll say Public
Access as yes guys because I want to
access this RDS database from my Azure
VM correct so Public Access has to be
yes okay because from aure I'm going to
use AWS uh database here and that is
over the Internet so Public Access has
to be yes so it can be no if you want to
access let's say this RDS database from
ec2 instance of AWS only correct so you
can you can keep Public Access as no but
if you want to access it from outside of
AWS let's say on premises or assure VM
so then you'll have to give the public
accesss that's what I say here and then
that's it and then I would do what uh
see Security Group I can go with the
default Security Group that's not a
problem okay so I'll just in uh put some
rule in that Security Group later but I
can right now go with the default
Security Group and availability zone no
preference that's all fine and that's it
guys
and then what I can do is I can just
create this database
okay fine this is not required then
password authentication is good enough
okay so I can just create this database
okay so I'll just hit on create this
database server okay so I'll just say
create
database fine so I've have created this
RDS database server it's almost getting
created then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to once this is created so let it
create until that point what I will do
is I'll open Cloud shell in AWS guys
that I can use as my uh client as my uh
database client okay through this uh
through this Cloud shell in AWS I can
just connect to my connect to what
connect to my uh RDS database server
here correct I can just show you this
diagram okay
uh see this diagram I had shown you now
so uh not this one
maybe oh this one not too sure right so
uh this will be my client so client will
connect to this database server and will
create a database and the table in my in
my in my database server so this as a
client I can have I can use a client
from I mean I can install a my SQL
client on my local machine on my laptop
and through that also I can connect to
my database server or I can use as a as
a as a MySQL client I can also uh use
this uh what I can also do it through
Cloud shell in AWS correct so that I can
make it work as my my SQL client and
through that I can connect to this
database server so I'll open up this
Cloud shell here
correct so through this Cloud shell also
I can connect to my database server so
that can also act as my client isn't
it so on this Cloud shell I will have to
install what I will have to install the
CLI my SQL CLI
correct so I'll have to install the
MySQL CLA so for that maybe the command
will be Pudo yum update and Pudo yum
install MySQL okay so I'll just use the
command Pudo yum update and Pudo uh yum
install my
SQL I'll just give that command here
Pudo yum update and and sudo yum install
MySQL so this will install uh MySQL uh
plus uh I mean update it will do and
then it will install the my SQL as well
so this will install my SQL here okay so
I'll say yes no whatever so I'll just
say yes
why see so this is good my SQL uh oh
sorry in my AWS Cloud shell I've
installed the CLI and then I can work I
can connect to my database server and
create the uh uh uh uh database and the
table in my database server from this
Cloud shell because because the CLI AWS
CLI has been installed here right guys
but before I do that before I connect to
my database server from this AWS Cloud
shell this client maybe I'll just first
go to my RDS database and see to it if
it has been
created so once it gets created I will
just copy its endpoint
okay okay so uh I'll just copy its
endpoint and uh then um I am going to
also modify the security group okay
because I will allow the MySQL traffic
to come on this database server so I
will allow the traffic to come from Port
3306 which is nothing but what um MySQL
uh which will allow traffic that is
MySQL traffic to come to this database
right what was the command to install uh
CLI okay I will give you that command in
the chat window maybe
here because there are some good number
of commands that are going to follow
later okay the database is yet getting
created guys okay uh okay now it is
successfully created the database
correct okay and uh once it is created
so I will just go to this database and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to get
its end point and I'm going to save it
somewhere because this is again later
I'm going to require it correct to
connect to this database from my assure
VMS so I'm going to copy this endpoint
guys and uh I am going to go here and
then I can say RDS end
point this again would be required later
correct so this is again the next thing
that I have done
here fine uh this is good now uh next
what I'll do is I'll just go to the
security group of this RDS instance that
was the default security group so that
is available in ec2 service so I'll just
go to ec2 service and then I'll go to
the security group
here where is my security group here it
is okay and I'm going to go to that
particular Security Group
guys okay now which default Security
Group is that okay maybe I have two so I
will just I don't I'm not sure which
which default Security Group is
associated with my RDS instance so maybe
in both the security groups I'll just
give that rule one is associated with my
RDS instance or otherwise go to your RDS
instance and see which Security Group it
is or I'll just go to both the default
security groups and I'll put that
particular rule that is uh 3306 traffic
to come from anywhere okay in the
inbound Port rules I'll just edit
it and I would uh okay this is already
given 3306 to come from anywhere in this
Security Group so I'll not change
this uh I'll go to the another Security
Group this is 70 this is
done so I'll go to another Security
Group and here in the inbound Port rules
I will allow what I will edit the
inbound security group
rules okay maybe here also uh I have it
okay I will say add Rule and then I'll
say custom
TCP and then I would uh go with what
3306 but that is already allowed
guys and I will allow it from anywhere
ipv4 it's already allowed I think
okay that is already allowed so I don't
need to give it again see on this
Security Group it is already allowed my
SQL Aurora traffic to come which works
on Port 3306 to come from anywhere
source 0.0.0.0 so that is allowed so I
don't need to put it again and even in
in in the other Security Group also in
the other default Security Group also it
is allowed if this would have not been
allowed I had created it before guys
that's why it is allowed but in your
case it won't be allowed so so then
you'll have to go to the inbound rules
and you will have to addit uh the
inbound rules and you'll have to add
this traffic so what you will be doing
is you will edit this and then you will
say add a rule and you will say custom
TCP maybe Port 3306 and then uh you will
say to allow it from anywhere ipv4 okay
so this is what you will have to do well
I had done it before that's why it is
already allowed okay fine so this is all
good uh fine uh so uh this this is all
good so this uh security I mean uh Port
3306 traffic the MySQL Aurora traffic is
allowed to come on this RDS database
server so this is all fine
correct fine so now let's go to this uh
particular client that is
uh from my uh Cloud shell uh where my
CLI is installed from this Cloud shell
client I will connect to my database
server RDS database server so I have a
command to connect guys and that command
I'm going to use here so the command is
like
this I can
uh I can just give it to
you this command and I can just put it
here and then I'm going to change it so
see my SQL uh U and then hph you and
then admin so username I have to give
anyways my username is not admin guys
but it is AWS gurus I'll just modify
this and then p and then the RDS
instance end point so whatever and then
Port 3306 it will work on that it will
connect but RDS instance end point
you'll have to give so that endpoint you
had copied guys and put it in your
notepad so
just I had copied it in my notepad so
I'll get that end point and then I'll
put it
there correct so I'm going to paste it
here so that I can connect to my
database server from this client from
this Cloud shell and then I can create
my uh database uh and the table correct
okay so I'll just execute this so see
it's asking me for the password now now
of course I know the password is what
ews
gurus see I'm connected correct so when
I type the password it doesn't appear uh
because because it's a password so in
Linux it's it doesn't appear here but
then um it it I I had entered the
password and I'm connected to my myql
stuff okay so now let's create a
database here okay so what I'll do is
I'll first create a database so maybe
any name I can give to my database so
let's say I'll say create
database uh and then the database name
so I'll say create
database and then the database name is
let's say demo so I'm creating a
database here semicolon I'll say so the
syntax is create database demo so I've
created this database demo guys okay and
then I will use this database so I'll
say use demo because I have to create
the table inside this database so I'll
say use demo so I'm inside my database
now see I'm in demo now and now I'll
create a table here okay so what I will
give the command to create a table guys
I'll give the uh command to create a
table so I can create a table with any
name and then I'll also have to specify
the uh data types and stuff that I have
to specify here no no no leave it yeah P
for password you can take it up but then
password after that we are providing it
correct okay and uh see I can give you
the commands here uh for creating the
table and of course to create a database
it was uh create
database and then datab base name
that was the command guys okay to create
a database of course there was a
semicolon after that and then use
database
name that's what I use and then I
created this table uh I mean I have to
create this table so I'll just create
this table so see what I'm specifying is
uh see this is what text that is copied
from external sources can contain
malicious script verify the scripts uh
uh verify the text below before passing
I'm good with this so see it will create
table customers okay and then the name
of the I mean inside that table
customers I'm creating two Fields uh in
its schema that is name and address
field and name will be having the data
type whereare 30 character type it would
be and it should not contain a null
value and address also is uh character
type uh 30 the size would be and then it
should not contain a null again okay so
see query okay zero rows affected so
I've been able to create this database
uh and the table inside the database
guys and of course if I say
DC and then if I if I give the table
name so I will be able to see the table
uh schema here so see uh this table
contains name address correct but will I
be able to select any rows from this
table
guys so if I say select star from table
name will I be able to get
anything will I be be able to get
anything from this table the answer is
no why see no rows empty set why because
we have not inserted any data in this
table correct so that we will insert it
from the backend VM of aour and the
backend VM of azure will get that data
from the sqsq it will pull it from the
AWS sqsq and AWS sqsq will uh have that
data we'll get that data from the
frontend Azure VM
correct okay so from the frontend Azure
VM we'll put the data in sqsq of AWS and
then from that sqsq of AWS we'll pull
the data data through our backend assure
of uh through our backend VM of aure and
then from that backend VM of assure
we'll try to insert that data into this
table of my database and then I will
query Then I then after that if I'll
query that particular table from my
client from this uh Cloud shell okay so
I will see those records in the table
which I don't see right now is it clear
till this point guys yes is this clear
so if this is clear maybe I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm almost done with the AWS part of
it okay so then I have to go into Azure
and create the 2vm in Azure see we
created the sqsq we created the uh RDS
database server the database the table
in that through our client we created
the database and the table uh and then
um what now is the and we have also
created an IM IM user we have assigned
Amazon sqs full access and RDS full
access to it we have the CLI credentials
for our IM user now let's go to a azure
and let's create two VMS in aure which I
already created guys because of time
constraint so I've already created the
VMS in aure correct and then through
those VMS I'll just log to my what user
of AWS correct and then through my user
of AWS I'll login on this VMS and then I
will use some commands I'll install the
python script and then through that
script I will connect to my sqsq and
then RDS and we'll do the things here
okay so let's go and do that so let's go
to aure correct so are you good till
this
point ah see abishek why both VMS are in
Azure not one in Azure not one in AWS
see you can have both the VMS in AWS you
can have both the VMS in Azure you can
have one VM in Google Cloud Platform One
inure absolutely your choice okay in
fact the similar kind of lab I've been
taking up in only AWS also in only AWS
also for that the diagram is just
similar I've drawn
just that the
diagram here says instead of two VMS in
aure they are the two VMS in AWS only
ec2 instances correct but then I would
need that user there I mean I can just
work with roles and then stuff that I
had done in AWS correct but here we are
uh seeing multicloud thing
correct okay yeah Anusha so I am see we
can create any VMS in Azure Windows
Linux I've created the Linux VMS in
Azure correct correct
fine okay
guys so I hope I'm taking you along guys
you people are getting it okay although
uh it is not the basic stuff that we are
discussing here uh you should be good
with the services to understand this but
I'm taking you along here isn't it right
I'm making sure that
thing okay fine uh so let's get ahead so
may I get a confirmation yeah are you
all good till this point yes yes you're
enjoying it
yeah are those VMS in private subnet no
those VMS are in public subnet that I
have created right okay and I have
assigned them the public
IPS okay good good good good good
fine so here we go guys and then see I
have created two VMS in AWS already okay
and those VMS are which VMS my front end
vm1 and uh that is in rg1 Resource Group
created that already the backend vm2 and
the front end vm1 I've already created
those
VMS is there a significance of both VMS
in aure see as far as the significance
you would say now so here I'm telling
you this scenario with multicloud see
multicloud is the era correct now it is
like your organization or maybe
anybody's organization nowadays see um
you normally don't go with just one VM
okay I mean sorry you normally just
don't go with one uh cloud provider if
you have to use public Cloud platform
let's say you use some services from one
cloud and some services from the other
Cloud platform so then if that is the
case let's say if we are using the uh VM
service in assure and maybe the other
services in AWS how can we connect with
them correct so I'm showing you that
thing so you can do the same task with
AWS VMS also and you not go with
multicloud platform but then multic
cloud is the error because normally
organizations are into multiple clouds
and that's why you are learning multiple
clouds CLS and then if you're learning
multiple clouds you should also know
that how you can connect those clouds
correct so there are different ways of
connecting you can provide s side to
side connectivity uh and between the
networks also of azure AWS correct
and yeah so so so basically uh in this
lab uh that's why we are we are using
some services from AWS some from assure
to also show you that how you can work
with multic clouds here correct not just
for seeing but I'm showing you how you
can do it why can't we use terraform see
you can always use it no worries see you
can create your VMS in Azure through
armm templates also you can create them
through terraform as well you can always
do
it right abake yeah got it good okay
yeah and yeah so the other guy who has
asked maybe the numbers are written so I
hope that is clear to you right so now
guys see I am I've already created this
VM so so I'm not going to create the VMS
again but just I'll just show it to you
so while I created these VMS so what the
things I had done um so uh one second
before that I'll just delete this
Resource Group so that you don't have
any confusion
here because this is not required here
for
me test RG just be test BM okay now uh
let me just uh quickly show you that
which VM I had created and which
configuration I have specified uh okay
because I had already created that VM so
to save time but I can just show it to
you uh what I had done while creating
the VM see one thing when you have to
create your VMS in aure you have to
create it inside a subscription and a
resource Group okay uh any resource in
in in in aure and I am creating it in
msdn platform subscription being a
Microsoft certified trainer I have
access to msdn platform subscription
correct okay
uh sure
yeah
fine fine fine I'm doing that anyways
right so uh then the virtual machine
name
uh uh see I had given the virtual
machine name then the region name then
availability Zone if required i' had
given it if not I had just said no
infrastructure redundancy uh then uh I
had gone with uban 2 server guys uban 2
20.4 and then uh I'd given the SSH
public key and then in that I had given
the username and then uh I had generated
a key pair okay and then I had given SSH
and HTTP maybe and that way I have
created two VMS okay once I have created
these VMS guys okay so now I will just
show you how I can connect to those VMS
and then we will install some scripts so
I'll just go to front end VM okay and
then I'll connect to this front end VM
so I'll just go to connect connect and
then so I'll go to connect and then I'll
just go to bashian here so I I'll go to
bashian ban host okay because I've
created a Bashan host also to securely
connect to my VM so you can just create
and then you can connect through it so
this is the username for my VM uh and uh
I had given SSH private key from my that
I had generated while I was creating the
VM so I'll just take that frontend uh
vm1 key.pem that is and I'll say connect
so this will connect to my
vm1 okay okay and similarly then I'll
connect to my vm2 as
well so I'll just go to backend
VM and then so to do it faster only I
just created these VMS before only a
right so because it takes time to create
the V uh actually the Bashan host
otherwise right so then I'll I'll go to
backend
VM and then I'll go to basan here
EST here and then I'll give the username
here
again and then of course uh the SSH
private key file from local uh file and
then I'll give
that here backend
vm2 and then I'll say
connect I'll connect to this particular
backend VM as well so see I'm connected
to my front end VM and I am connected to
my backend VM correct
so front end VM and backend VM I am
connected to guys
correct so this is my front end VM for
at frontend VM and then this is my
backend VM correct now let's put some uh
scripts here and let's execute
it then
okay yeah VMS can have same username
okay so that's not a
problem purpose of remembrance I've
given them the same name okay so now
guys uh let's uh go with some commands
and let's do it here
then okay so first of all uh what I'm
going to do here is uh I'm going to
enter uh this command name on both the
VM so I'll say Pudo apt get update in on
both the VMS to update the things okay
I'll just give this command on this VM
also front end VM as well and I'll just
put it on the back end VM as
well okay I can give it to you in the
chat window as
well okay so I'm not taking the queries
here because we are running short of
time here so I'll just quickly do
this okay so I've just put Pudo app get
update on both the VM SK and this is
done this is installed and then I'll say
uh sud sudo so then I'll install the AWS
CLI on both of my VMS correct so AWS CLI
I'll install because I have to connect
through that user AWS user through its
XS key ID and secret xess key correct so
I'll just install what the AWS CLI on
both the users on both the VMS correct
so I will just say AWS sorry sudo app
get install AWS CLI okay I will give it
to you in the CH window again this
command so see I will say why or no I'll
say why here where it is man here y I'll
say and I'll enter here and then I'll
put it on the back end VM as
well AWS CLI I'll just go with Y here as
well okay so let it
install and then I will just login with
those with that user user one of aw SK
so for that I'll give the command AWS
configure okay and then I'll give that
users credential that AWS user
credential uh through which we want to
log to Azure VMS correct so through AWS
user we we want to log to the Azure VM
so I'll give that user credentials for
that I'll say AWS configure here first
correct so let it execute and then I'll
say AWS configure and then I'll put that
users access key ID and secret access
key to login with that user uh
on my front end VM of azure and backend
VM of azure okay so I'll just do
that so let it happen and then I will
just go and do
that yeah I hope it would be
done you can try it out
satjit okay so uh I think it's almost
done now uh on backend V also it's
getting done yeah it is done so now
let's say AWS configure guys here okay
I'll just give it to you in the chat
window AWS configure it is the command
okay now I'll say AWS configure and then
I'll say enter and it will ask me for
the XS key ID of that user and secret XS
key now this command is working because
I've I've installed the AWS CLI on this
VM correct with that command that's why
so XIs key ID I'll just get it from here
okay before I get xess key ID I'll just
run the same command on the second VM
also AWS configure and I'll put the
exess key ID on both the VMS to make it
faster uh I'll just copy this and then I
will put it on my backend VM plus I'll
put it on my front end VM then it ask me
for the secret access key so I'll get
the secret access key guys I'll copy
this and then I will put it on my front
end VM I will also put it on my backend
VM correct and then the region name so
you can give any name uh uh any region
name so maybe uh you can give any uh
region name so let's say in uh in AWS it
is like you can give it as us East one
the region name okay so maybe Us East
one for North Virginia you can give any
name guys that's not a problem uh so
this is the region code so I'm saying Us
East one
and then the output format so it can be
table format text format or Json format
I'll just go with table format so I'm
done I'm logged in with puru at backend
vm2 okay I mean I'm logged in with that
user AWS user now okay and then I will
give it here also the region uh maybe as
us East
one and then uh the output format may be
a stable format
okay so I'm done I am logged in with
those users correct now we will set up
the VMS as front end and backend VMS by
using the Python scripts okay so um I'll
first say app get install by python okay
so I'll install the python
here on both the VMS so I'll just give
this command
here and
uh one second permission Deni
what happened to
this okay so why permission denied guys
because I'm not in the super user so
I'll have to come to super user and then
I'll have to execute this command so
I'll just come to super user then so
I'll say sudo
Su
okay and then I will uh say
what app get update I can just give
it
app uh get update I can
say app hyen get and then update maybe
right okay so I'll just say hyen app get
update
okay I'll just execute
this and then I will say what uh then I
say app get install y python
okay now it would be done okay I can
give you that in the chat window but
before that I'll just do it on my other
VM also so I'll say sudo
Su then I'll say
apt
get
update and then I'll give that
command by python okay I can give it to
you in the chat window sudo
Su and then
apt get
update and then I'll give you that
command as well quickly here okay fine
okay so we are done uh with this uh now
we'll say appt install Python 3
pip IP address I'll install okay so I'll
just do it on both the instances this is
on the first
instance so I'm setting up this
environment guys
correct so I'll say y
here and I'll sa why here as
well okay on on on on on on this VM
maybe I've done
it okay I'll just say again
okay so I'll say
why okay I can give it to you as
well and then I'll install the boto3
library correct of python to let the
things happen because I want to put the
things in my sqsq also right okay so
I'll say uh What uh pip install boto
let me see it's done here so I'll just
install pip install boto
3 I'll give it to
you I'll put it on my another VM
also
okay then I'll put this command by
python I get install by python I think
this is already done but I'll just
execute it once
again I'll give it to you and uh then
what see I'm already in the super user
correct so I don't need to do H sudo suu
again so I'll say app AB get update also
I had install I had done before I'll
just do it again AB get
update and then I'll say app get install
y python okay
yeah I'll I'll I'll I'll do that I will
run that script as
well install python okay
install this is done here so here also I
will do that
apt get update one
second
install then okay I think you had
already done this so uh app get update I
can just put it again but I think you
have already done that before we have
done that but I'll just put it again and
then uh of course this command also I
can give it to
you
install
python okay uh fine so this is there and
then um okay maybe I'll say apt install
Python 3 pip again on both the VMS this
is the command for the
same it's already done okay done with
four this was done anyways okay maybe
I'll just put it again pip install boto
3 okay and I can give it to you this
one here El I'll put that okay
fine
and then uh what I'll do guys uh I'll
install my SQL connector for python uh
on the backend VM not on the front end
VM that is not required okay so on the
back end only I'll just install the
MySQL connector for python because that
my I mean your back end VM only wants to
connect to the uh MySQL correct not the
front end VM so this uh command that I'm
going to give you now needs to be done
only on the backend VM correct you you
can do it on the front end VM also but
then that is not required okay so uh
that is there fine so on the backend
VM I will just go and I will just give
this command pip install my SQL
connector
python okay and then what um
yeah fine
so this is good
uh maybe okay front end VM I think I had
closed it so I'll again connect to my
front end VM and then I will create a
file on my front end VM now okay so I'll
just go to my front end VM I'll just
Clos it anyways I had executed those
commands so I don't need to execute them
again so I will just go to Bashan and we
connect to my frontend VM
again
and I'll give the script now I'll give
the script that will uh uh what that
will uh insert the records in my sqsq
correct so I'm on my front end VM now
correct so now what I am going to do is
I am going to
uh create a file here correct so I am
basically am going to create a file here
correct okay so uh for
that I am going to do what I'm going to
create a script
here is the required python connector
only on back end or both only on backend
that should be good Anusha right if you
want to do it on front end you can do it
but that is not required okay so now I
will just create a file here okay so
what is the file name I can just specify
so I can just say maybe sud sudo Nano uh
I mean I can uh just create a file here
okay uh send message. piy or any file so
I'll just say sudo
Nano okay sorry uh I can just say sudo
Nano and then the file name I can give
it is it can be what uh send message. Pi
I can give any name to my file let's say
send
message
dopy okay so I'll just create this file
send message
dopy and now in this file I'm going to
put this script guys so I can just show
you that script what I am going to put
there okay so this is the script uh
maybe that I am going to put here or I
can just show it to you in the chat
window here
so see this is the script uh I mean on
the notepad here so I can give it give
you the script as well in the chat
window here so see in this I'm going to
say import sis import boto 3 library
because I've already installed that
included that then boto 3. CLI sqs then
Q URL so here I'll have to give that sqs
Q's URL that I had copied from Amazon
sqs and I had put it here see sqs URL so
that I will put it here correct guys so
I will just replace this with this Q
URL correct so I'll just get this Q URL
from here itself and I'll just put it
here
itself correct okay so I'll just paste
it here it
say right and then responses sqs do send
message so that will send the message
message body print message ID correct so
then uh let me copy this script and put
it here so see sqs Q your sqsq url
you'll have to put it there so I'll just
copy this and then I will just go here
and I'll just paste it here correct okay
so I have uh just pasted it here okay
uh but I don't see it uh in the nicest
way so maybe I'll go through VI editor
so I'll just say control X and I'll uh
just say control X and then I'll say no
I'll not save it uh I'll just go through
VI editor so I'll say VI um and then
what uh send message send underscore
message uh do PI I'll go
with and then I will uh put the script
here okay now this is good seems good
okay and then I will say Escape coland
WQ okay so I am out of that okay so
instead of the Nano I'm going with VI
editor and then uh I'm putting that
script and uh that is what I have put
that script guys now okay now uh this is
all good
okay uh okay now I can give the commands
to actually send the data to my sqsq
okay so for that the command is uh
Python 3 send message. pi and then the
message that I want to put so maybe I
can just use this command maybe I can
just say uh sorry what have I
done oh man I've again pasted that same
thing uh am I doing
that okay I just ignore this okay so now
get this command uh because I just
pasted that script file again here that
is not required so see uh what I'm going
to do here is I'm going to execute this
command Python 3 sendor message
uh Python 3 send uncore message
and
uh then whatever the message I want to
put in my sqsq so I'll just try to
execute
this okay that I is missing okay in the
import okay so I'll just go to my file
VI
file okay maybe I'll just say
VI and then what is there Python 3
Python 3 uh no sorry VI send message. pi
send underscore
message
dop uh okay this in the import uh the I
is missing okay so I'll just go to
insert mode and I will put that I here
okay and now it's good I'll say Escape
colon WQ to save and exit and then I
will uh just put that command uh that is
Python 3 send message and which message
I'm trying to s Peter USA see it has
been sent into my sqsq I'll try to put
another message okay from my Azure VM
I'm trying to put this message and it is
getting put guys I mean uh it is getting
inserted so maybe another message I'll
just put in here I will say uh Peter USA
instead of that I will say Simon
Australia maybe or any message so s
Simon
Australia okay okay so now this message
would be there in the queue okay so this
is also inserted so let me post put
another message maybe the third message
here so I'll say Clark
Germany Clark Germany okay uh and then
guys I'll show you the beauty okay we'll
go to our sqsq and we'll see those
messages there okay so see we have put
these three messages in our sqsq from
our Azure VM now let's go to AWS let's
go to AWS and let's go to sqsq in AWS
okay so I'll just go to sqsq and you
will see those messages in sqsq in AWS
correct so you will see those messages
guys so if you go to this queue see
there are three messages here itself it
was
showing it it it it shows me two
messages I'll just refresh it see three
messages are available correct okay so
it is three message yeah yeah like rapid
mq yeah sqsq correct so uh you have
three messages in Azure the option you
have got with service bus okay uh like
sqs and ews so here you have got three
messages and you can pull those messages
guys so you can say you can go to send
and receive messages and then you can uh
you can see there are three messages and
you can say poll you don't see those
messages so you can say Poll for
messages okay and then you will see
those messages see you see those
messages if you click here you will see
Simon Australia correct then the second
one Peter USA right then the third one
Clark Germany is it not good guys yes is
it clear to you yes is it clear till
this point yes so from our a frontend VM
of azure we are able to push the
messages we are able to insert the
messages in sqsq we have done till this
point is it clear till this point yes
quickly if you can tell me so then we
will go yeah yeah so then we'll go to
backend VM of Azure and then we will try
to pull this messages from our sqsq of
AWS and we will insert it in the table
of our AWS in RDS and then we will query
the table of our RDS through the client
of um uh AWS and then we'll be able to
see those messages there in the table
correct okay so that's what we'll do
then okay so this is done now um fine so
now I will
uh go to the Azure back end okay uh uh
so I'll go to where I'll go to the back
end of azure okay so I'll just go to the
back end of azure anyway so this is
front end so back end I'll just connect
to my back end VM in aure and I just
switched it off so
uh very systematically teaching yeah
thank you thank you thanks for the
appreciation
yeah that keeps me motivated so now uh
let me just go to the backend VM of
azure
I'll just go to local
file back end vm2 now it's just that we
are coming to the end
only okay uh so now uh we are into the
backend VM of azure guys and then um
I'll create a uh What uh maybe I will
just create uh uh uh uh What uh um a
script here also get message. by Script
a python script here as well okay so
I'll just give it uh maybe
VI uh what I'll say
VI get
message get uh underscore message I can
give any name
okay
Pi okay so I'll just get inside this and
here what I'm going to put guys so I'll
just show it to you to
you okay now this script has uh some
good lines so I'll just put it
here okay maybe I'll just show it to you
here so I just go
here and I can give it to you in the
chat window as well
guys oh where is that when not put
that is it not getting put in the chat
window so here in the chat window see I
had put the first script but then the
second script is not getting copied in
the chat window I don't know
why I said everyone I'm saying paste but
why it is not getting copied I don't
know
why but somehow it is not getting pasted
in your chat window the second
script anyways uh don't worry uh let me
explain you and then I will put this uh
uh notepad itself here right
okay right so I'll just do that just a
second yeah so uh let me just put this
uh uh so let let me explain you import
time library then import uh boto 3
import my SQL connector then uh the Q
URL so here I'll have to give the Q URL
correct so sqs Q URL so what was that
this was it correct so uh this is the SQ
because see this script will not just
put the messages in your database in in
AWS but will also get those messages
from sqsq and then we'll put it in the
database correct so this is the Q URL
uh correct and then specify the so it
will get the uh data from this sqsq then
specify the database details so here
I'll have to give the database host name
guys okay so host name of the database I
had saved it here somewhere Rd is
endpoint correct so that I have to give
here AWS Cru do something something if
you don't remember you can get it from
AWS itself correct uh so for that uh you
will have to go to RDS and then you will
have to get it from them there if you
don't remember then you'll have to go
here and then uh you will have to get it
from the databas is
here the endpoint and Port so endpoint
you can get it from here but anyways we
do have it so uh I'll just copy it from
here itself and then I will just put it
where guys in the database details
here
okay so this is good now username is
what so my username is AWS gurus guys
it's not admin I know that correct
otherwise you can get it from the
details of the database then again
configuration part here username and
stuff okay uh the instance ID see Master
username AWS gurus uh the password again
I have it as AWS gurus that I know so
I'll just put it here so you will have
to update these things in the database
and then the database that we are having
so the database that we had created
through client guys was what the name
was demo correct the database name was
what demo see it was demo now see here
use demo create database demo so we had
created the demo database so demo
database we are using
it okay uh so demo database we'll use it
and then um create an sqs client so
boto3 client sqs then connect to RDS
MySQL instance so MySQL connector.
connect and then host name is what this
is the host name so I can just give that
host name anyways that uh need not have
to be given in the quotes correct so the
quotes are not required so host name
would be given as is without quotes
because it's like you're directly giving
the host name correct then the
what then the uh username is not admin
but
uh it is AWS gurus or you can say
username is a user only you can say user
is user because that AWS gr you have
already put it in user variable then
password you have put it in password
variable so since it's a variable so it
does not has to be put in single quotes
it if it would have been a direct name I
had to put it in the single quotes So
this is all good and then database in
the database variable name is there
correct so it could have been any other
variable name whatever the variable name
you have used here you need to give that
variable name here after equals to
correct so my cursor is my db. cursor
then receive messages from sqsq so I'll
say sqs do receive message then Q URL so
qore URL is where you have the Q URL
correct so I'm specifying that Q URL
then message response then delete I mean
see you just don't have to uh get the
messages from the Q but you will have to
then delete those messages from q and
then insert it into the table in your
database so I will delete the received
messages from the queue then and and
then from uh Q name is present in Q URL
correct so that is here in Q URL
variable it is there the Q uh URL and
then what then we will uh print this
received and deleted message and the
message body and then we will get the
customer name and address from the
message so whatever is the message that
we'll get uh name and C address that
would be displayed guys uh that would be
displayed and then would be inserted
into the database so I'm then going to
record uh write those record into the
database in which table in customer
table because in my database I have
created the customer table in that I
have the name and the address field so
see here also we have the name and the
address field okay so that is what we
are doing we are committing it my db.
comit and then print inserted uh record
inserted in the database that is what we
are printing here so guys this is what
the script is I have just made you
understand the script as well now let's
just use this script so I'll just go
here and I am going to use it here on my
backend VM so I'll just paste it here
correct so this script is pasted and
then what I will say I'll say Escape
colon WQ I'll save exit from this script
okay uh so I'll just save and exit uh
this script so I am good with this
script okay and yeah and then uh what
next I am actually done now so I will uh
just get uh some um I'll use some
commands now okay um so I will I will I
will do what now
[Music]
um
okay fine so I'll just give this Pudo
yeah check entries not not not right now
not right now let me execute this script
now okay let me execute the script I've
just given that script correct so uh now
let me execute this script so I'll I'll
execute this so while what I'll say I'll
say sudo Nano get message dot Pi maybe
in this it is there now
already okay this is already there so
this is all good fine uh so I'll just
say control
x uh okay I am out of this okay and and
then what I will type now is I'll say
get message. Pi okay yeah Python 3 get
message. piy that will serve me the
purpose now okay so I'll say Python 3
get message
dopy okay I'll execute
that okay so I'll just say what Python 3
get message. pi and I'll execute this
okay uh uh uh uh uh okay again in this
get message. py there is that import
error
saying oh why is that input error okay
maybe I'll say
VI okay get
message do PI maybe in the copy pasting
I've done that
error in import time yeah yeah see again
that import time import time instead of
so I'll just go to I and then uh I'll go
to insert mode and then I will just give
it there there is this error import Time
Escape colon WQ okay I'm out and let me
execute that Python 3 get message. Pi
see received and deleted the message
Peter USA Record inserted in the
database correct guys and now how by
pressing I you can go to insert mode now
if you want to check it out you can
check it out in your database so now you
can just go to RDS and then guys in RDS
now from this client from this Cloud
shell you say select star from customers
and you will see one record see can you
see Peter USA yeah can you see Peter USA
guys so this one record has been
inserted in your table and not just this
is inserted in your table but this has
been deleted from that queue so if you
want to see whether it has been deleted
from the queue or not so you can just go
to
sqsq and then you can just see to it
that it has been deleted from the queue
okay not just inserted in your table but
should have been deleted from the queue
so if you go to that demo que correct if
you go to the demo que and then uh if
you if you go to send and receive
messages so you would see that if you uh
pull the if you pull the messages then
you will only see two m messages here
now see two messages only not three
messages Simon Australia and what uh
Clark Germany well the first message has
been deleted which message which message
guys Peter USA is no longer there
correct Peter USA is no longer there
okay right now uh let me just put I mean
let me just execute that command again
then the second message will also be
deleted and if I execute that command
the third time then the third message
will also be deleted and will be
inserted into the que see the second uh
message okay I'll have to execute it
again and then it will come up see
received and deleted message Simon
Australia correct so now Simon Australia
has been received and deleted and put in
the uh database then I'll execute it
again and now the Clark Germany has been
also uh pulled from the queue deleted
from the queue and inserted in your
database you can go here uh you can just
check out in the queue two messages were
showing you can just refresh it and you
will not see a single message you can
say Poll for messages and this time you
will uh not receive any message see you
don't see any message it's just polling
only it's not finding out any message in
fact if you go to your demo que directly
you can uh see uh that there are now
zero messages if you refresh
it see there are zero messages available
no message in the queue and if you go to
your RDS client okay if you if you say
select star from table name now you will
see all those three messages here Peter
USA Simon Australia Clark Germany isn't
it guys it's all there yeah yes or no is
this clear to all of
you
yeah in one go can we pull all the
messages here you can then run it maybe
in a script again you can give it and
then you can run it in a in a while loop
maybe and then you can execute that
script isn't it
shredda yeah so that was there guys from
my end yeah so that's how you can
execute it is it clear yeah so we have
we have actually executed this whole
thing this complete project isn't it
right um so front end ec2 instance
pushing the messages in the queue
inserting the messages in the queue in
AWS Q then backend VM from assure is
pulling it out from the queue and
deleting it and putting it into the
table in our RDS database and through
the client we are able to query that
table correct so yeah that was it from
my uh this particular demo was concerned
yeah thank you I hope it is clear to all
of you yeah I hope you liked it maybe
how was it did you did you got it
yeah thank you Dr Pam for an insightful
session
today uh thank you I hope all our
audience enjoyed what they learned today
and I would love to see your response on
the
chat uh I quickly share my screen we can
discuss the further
slides yeah I think they have liked it
yeah thank you that's amazing we have
very responsive audience today as well
so it is a really interactive session
thank
you thank you thank you and I will just
give you this file as well in the chat
window I'll just put it because that
script I was unable to um put it so
maybe this data file I'll just create it
and I'll just put it in the chat window
for you can get the script from this
okay you can proceed yeah a that please
thank
you thank you everyone for your
responses moving on uh now that uh this
is just one of the projects that you'll
be going through in the coures which
will'll be discussing in the full coming
slides uh there are many more projects
like this and I looking at the
enthusiasm today I really think you guys
will really enjoy the different projects
in the course uh so now that you know
the different projects that we be having
and such projects you will be uh
implementing we would love to know what
really stopping you from becoming a
cloud computing in Delux expert uh is
that you are not finding a completely
comprehensive curriculum uh is it that
uh you're not getting enough practical
exposure that you to become job ready or
is it uh difficult to learn from
pre-recorded videos or is your work
schedule just not allowing the time so I
quickly launch the poll you can punch in
your answers it's a multiple choice
question so you can punch in your
multiple problems uh if you can't find a
comprehensive curriculum you don't have
practical exposure or you find it
difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos or you work schedule doesn't
allow you I will keep the poll open for
a few more
seconds I would request all of you to
punch in your
mes thank you all for your
responses as I can see most of them have
a variety of problems they are not
finding a comprehensive program or is it
the Practical exposure is lacking in
courses or it's difficult to learn from
pre-recorded videos or your work
schedule doesn't allow the time so to
overcome all these challenges simply
learn has come up with a unique program
called the professional certificate
program in cloud computing and devops uh
it's in collaboration with the IIT goart
and it's a comprehensive uh comprises of
a comprehensive industry learning part
it has integrated labs and projects
which just went through one of them uh
you'll have online virtual class rooms
with live instruct interaction just like
how you experience today and it will
also be flexible to fit your schedule
this program is about for eight months
which you will be able to complete if
you invest from 10 to 15 hours a
week coming to the eligibility criteria
of this program you may not be uh it's
not necessary for you to be from a
programming background
uh you need to have a high school
diploma or equivalent and you need to be
at least 18 years of age and there is no
uh compulsion that you need to have any
work experience to enroll for this
program uh this is how the program will
build your development skills step by
step uh I would request purushotam s to
just quickly take us through the steps
and what will be the learnings from this
program right so um see first of all um
we we'll have introduction session for
cloud computing boot camp okay um if if
you opt for this course then uh there'll
be there'll be a course on adws cloud
fundamental so that will that will talk
about the fundamental aspects in Cloud
uh in AWS specifically um so it would be
like you'll become jack off many
services not the master of them uh then
in designing applications and
architectures in AWS you will Master
some Services good service and uh
services and you will understand the
architect concept the design aspects uh
in AWS Cloud um that can help you in the
architect role as well uh then of course
uh you will go into Azure Cloud
fundamentals so again that will talk
about the fundamentals of azure related
to like AZ 900 Azure fundamentals and uh
you'll become Jack of many services
there but not the master of them then uh
you can study on Implement uh manage and
monitor on Azure environment so that
will help you get in the Practical
handson into Azure Implement manage and
monitor on Azure environment uh then
designing infrastructure Solution on
Azure this is like architecting in Azure
so um you'll see the uh uh design
aspects also of it and many services the
handson you will cover up uh then of
course uh then uh you come up with cloud
computing boot camp Capstone project so
so so so so similar to these projects
one that we have taken here which will
include uh like uh the multicloud
structure in picture like uh Azure AWS
or maybe uh different Cloud providers
together the services from them and then
uh will have the Capstone project
related to this uh one of the examples
just we have seen today right so that uh
that would be covered then later and of
course so these are the compulsory
things so once you will complete all
these things you will get the uh
certificate from uh the program uh the
program certificate correct and apart
from that uh there are electives also
like apart from these compulsory courses
you can also go for these electives um
that is IIT goari faculty master class
so uh The Faculty from IIT goari will
will will will take this master class
for you then of course Google Cloud
platform architect training if you wish
to you can go for that as well now these
are not compulsories but then uh you can
opt for one or all of them as well big
data on AWS devops on assure uh Native
AI master class and many more of course
that would be there right so uh these
are things you'll go through yeah so the
electives you can take one or all of
them they are included in the price
which comes from the program so you
don't have to pay anything extra for
that uh coming to the projects there
will be many such projects one of them
which we discussed today deploy a
multitime rep app similarly we have
multiple projects which you can undergo
during the program and we will have our
mentors guiding me through
the uh projects step by step as
today moving on we'll have some of the
global leaders as program advisers Dr
will be
from and ICT at I be a part of this
program coming to to uh apart from the
program we also provide job assist
Service uh which has three parts uh we
will help you with the
resume job portal where you'll be able
to uh have a look at different jobs
after the program and can apply for jobs
which will have a wide employer Network
you'll also be given a resume review and
rewrite service which will help you
enhance your resumes and land that dream
interview that you're always looking for
we will also provide you with one-on-one
interview service where you be
interviewed by some of the leading
subject matter experts who will give you
continuous feedback and help you improve
your interviews as
well so now that you know what will be
offered during the program I will
quickly run a call if you would like to
enroll for this IIT GUI professional
certificate program in cloud computing
and
devops it's a simple yes or no answer if
you would like to enroll for the program
you can just just punch in
yes I will request all the participants
today to punch in your responses either
yes
or I keep the poll open for another 5
Seconds thank you all for your responses
I'll end the poll
now uh I'll quickly run through the
enrollment steps of this program the
three simple Steps step one you need to
send an application you can just email
us at ask USS simply learn.net I will
also post uh
the course Link in the chat so that it's
easier for you to visit the course page
and uh drop in your links as well
there paste the link
here once you send in the application
our team at I will review your
application your educational background
down your work experience and other
things and once it's approved our
learning consultant will contact you
with the admission better that's the
three simple steps just need to send an
application ask us at we learn
talk coming to the program fees and
enrollment schedule uh the program is
priced at 1ak
24,999 including taxes uh we also have
Emi options uh which starts from 4,254
rupees per month uh if you are
interested to enov for the program
immediate our next cohort starts from
the 2nd of December and the in induction
session for the same cohort will be on
held on 8th of
November uh let me remind our attendance
today that there are limited seats
available so for every cohort I would
request you to enroll immediately so for
any further assistance you can always
email us at ask us at c.net and we will
be able to answer all your
qus
so a quick poll uh how soon do you plan
to enroll uh is it
immediately uh within 3 months uh or
within six months or maybe after 6
months uh I would request all of you to
punch in your
responses so that uh we have an idea of
when you'll be enrolling for the
course I request all the participants to
punch in their
responses I keep the poll open for a few
more
seconds great great great great thank
you all for your
responses and one last poll before we
end the session for today uh do you need
any assistance with the enrollment
process
uh you launch the poll if you need any
assistance you can punch in and yes and
our team will get back to you and help
you with the further steps
I would request all of you to punch in
your
answers I keep the poll open for another
10 seconds before I close
it thank you all for your
responses so that's the end of our
session today uh I would like to thank
our uh Mentor for today Dr purushotam
for taking your time and explaining the
project so beautifully and it was a
really insightful session for all of us
uh we saw the responses from our
audience they really enjoyed it and
learned something for and I'm sure many
of them will be joining our your
learning community soon and we'll see
you on the other side thank you all for
joining us today uh I know it's a bit
too late but I apologize for the delay
but uh I really hope you have had a
great learning session I even apologize
for the delay no problem
we love the session because that was
quite ly isn't it yeah so thank you
thank you for U having me here yeah
thank you AA thank you everyone thank
you all sir uh yes uh we will be sending
you the recording of the session so
don't worry we'll be sending it followup
email before you leave uh once you leave
the webinar you'll have a poost webinar
survey please fill it up so that you'll
be getting the recording in your email
as well as the certificate for joining
us today thank you all for joining us
today good night have a great
day
and